[Música]
[Aplausos]
cuando me enteré que en argentina 129
mil personas vivían con vih me pregunte
porque cuando yo fui diagnosticado me
sentí tan solo porque nadie había
hablado del tema porque no conocía a
nadie cerca mío vih-positivo entonces
hice las cosas como suelo hacerlas mal y
a las apuradas
y decidí publicar en mis redes sociales
que era vih positivo
nunca lo hice con una con un pensamiento
activista sino que quería evitar esa
situación sabes del 11 ahí va lo pongo
en redes
la gente comenzó a preguntarme cosas
como ay cuando te vas a morir
no todavía no había me enoja o cosas
como han claro eso te pasa por gay o por
eso está usted tan flaco
pero sanz que también me escribió mucha
gente que empezó a contar sabes que mi
mamá también lo tiene mi papá mi hermano
mi amigo yo también soy vih positivo y
ahí me dieron y la pregunta es momento a
caso el vih no es solamente de gays o
una persona que se infectó en los años
80 todavía puede estar viva vih no es
igual a muerte porque confundimos vih
consigue ámense todas estas preguntas
digo este caso me han mentido los
periodistas
los spoilers la gente que miente y demás
me ha mentido acaso todos los medios
hegemónicos de comunicación me ha
mentido la dueña del barrio que lleva y
trae chismes
spoiler
tanto miedo tenía yo cuando fui
diagnosticado que no lo pude compartir
con mi familia mi mamá de hecho se
enteró por el diariero del barrio que le
dijo oiga doña nora compre el diario que
está educación una entrevista
ese nivel de miedo e inseguridad tenía
yo
y me pregunto cómo puede ser que por
ejemplo en honduras por día
tres personas se infectan con vih desde
el inicio de el primer paciente hasta el
2017 aproximadamente 36.000 personas
fueron diagnosticadas como es que no
conozcamos a nadie como que no lo
sepamos
es el momento en que deviene
vih-positivo decidí que yo no iba a
estar más solo y que iba a intentar de
que nadie más esté solo por eso estoy
acá porque yo lo que quiero es que todas
y todos ustedes vivan con vih
hace unos años preparamos unas camisetas
con mis amigos que decían tengo vih nos
las pusimos y salimos a dar besos y
abrazos gratis
lo más lindo de esta experiencia saben
que fue el transporte público
hora pico hora ras lleno de gente y
todos amablemente se alejaban y nos
dejaban pasar
me hizo muy bien
mis amigas y mis amigos comenzamos a dar
besos y abrazos gratis saben que yo no
sé el estado serológico de mis amigas y
mis amigos pero esta tarde ellos
tuvieron vih ellos empezaron a vivir con
vih desde ese momento ellos aprendieron
a preguntarme a consultar a acompañarme
en mi ignorancia cuando yo tampoco sabía
a cuando goleábamos y veíamos
bestialidades
ellos comenzaron a tener vih esta tarde
ellos y ellas recibieron muchos besos y
abrazos pero también mucha gente que les
dio la espalda mucha gente que venía con
esto hay pibes habrá uno vih gente que
nadie de mes ya sabes que un abrazo si
peso no moverse
en argentina hay una ley de educación
sexual integral que no se está aplicando
en los colegios
imaginen que distinto hubiese sido esa
tarde si las personas supiesen que una
persona veía che positiva que está en
tratamiento antirretroviral que toma la
medicación y que alcanza la
indetectabilidad no transmite el virus
en una relación sexual mucho menos en un
beso y un abrazo ese es el poder de la
información
porque así como yo no transmite el virus
la ignorancia se contagia
y mata
por eso con mi amigo son amarillo
decidimos tomar una acción viral en
torno al vih
creamos un cómic de cómo es mi vida
viviendo con una cepa de vih a la que
llamamos
dicho show se publica cada jueves en
agencia presentes el medio lgv temas
donde yo colaboro
esto fue una oportunidad para poder
hablar para poder traficar información
saben por ejemplo pudimos explicar que
no es lo mismo vih
y si da que el vih es el virus que
ingresa en el cuerpo y que ataca las
defensas y sin es tratado a tiempo
debieron estadio del sida parecería algo
lógico o sí claro no no se sabe este
dato lo más importante que pudimos hacer
con dicho yo fue a hablar
en un paradigma de silencio en un
espacio tan callado
en argentina aproximadamente un 20% de
las personas que viven con vih no lo
saben entonces con dicho yo pudimos
preguntar cuánto hace que no te test te
hace yo hoy les pregunto cuánto hace que
no toman un test de vih con dicho yo
pudimos hablar sobre todo en un momento
en el que no hay campañas de
concientización y saben que peor es
cuando una campaña solamente le habla el
cuerpo negativo y le dice cuidado
cuidado no te agarres esto y yo que lo
veo yo al revés o sea eso
no se le habla al cuerpo positivo no se
le cuenta el cuerpo vih-positivo que
somos cuerpos que vivimos que gozamos
que tenemos sexo es que trabajamos que
marchamos que existimos
a veces más miedo que al virus le tengo
a los gobiernos que nos abandonan a la
sociedad que nos da la espalda
y aún más miedo le tengo a los
guionistas porque no sobrevivimos a
ninguna serie ya ninguna película
entonces
y tendemos a hacer o víctima o amenaza
pero saben que con información
directamente no tenemos que caer en el
destino de ser estigmas prejuicios y
muerte tener información también es
vivir con vih eso es lo que le estoy
pidiendo desde que una sola persona en
esta sociedad tiene vih toda la sociedad
tiene vih hoy aquí todos ustedes tienen
vih por compartir esto y les pido que
tengan vih al momento de votar al
momento de marchar al momento de elegir
representantes al momento de hablar en
su casa sobre el tema o de no hablarlo
en el mundo aproximadamente 37 millones
de personas viven con el virus son casi
4 veces un poco más la población de
honduras imagina toda la gente con la
que ustedes han tenido sexo compartido
trabajo el sistema público y demás y no
lo saben y la pregunta es por qué no lo
saben porque tu mamá no te lo puede
decir porque tus tías porque tu hermana
porque tu amigo no te lo puede decir y
es que yo lo voy a compartir te esta
información si del otro lado vas a decir
y cuando te morís
si vas a decir pero andas y tengo es
peligroso conmigo para que te lo voy a
compartir esto en argentina desde 2015
hasta ahora las personas positivas hemos
tenido que salir a la calle más de tres
veces por faltantes de medicación y
porque vivimos con una ley del año 1990
que no esperaba que sigamos vivas y
vivos el año pasado no dejaron que
avance un proyecto para una nueva ley
cada vez que salimos a la calle
yo lo que busco no es tener vih sino
visibilidad
la primera vez éramos 50 personas en
2015 osea yo le decía un amigo mira si
no me mata el vih que no me mate un auto
porque estamos cortando una avenida
enorme
la segunda vez a éramos 200 personas yo
no sé si estas personas son vih
positivas o ellas negativas pero estaban
ahí con nosotras y con nosotros
marchando activando estas personas viven
con vih y es eso lo que necesitamos
yo podría este discurso estoy dando
cambiar la palabra argentina y poner
honduras porque aquí también falta
medicación aquí también faltan leyes en
honduras cerca de mil personas por año
contraen el virus tres personas por día
mueren con causas relacionadas al vih y
sida saben que yo no solo le estoy
pidiendo que tengan vih yo le estoy
pidiendo que tengan saben que empatía
la empatía que tuvieron mis amigas y mis
amigos cuando se pusieron esa remera y
salieron a tener vih
yo hago muchos chistes con respecto al
virus porque a veces me da mucho miedo
contar lo que realmente me está pasando
hablar de mis miedos e inseguridades
saben
el vih es un virus que ataca a tus
defensas
pero también las emocionales
a veces me siento indefenso
en el momento en que mis amigas y mis
amigos empezaron a tener vih conmigo ya
nunca más estuve solo
pero cuando comparto todo esto
obviamente haters y trolls en las redes
me dicen de todo lo que se puedan
imaginar en 2017 de este año pronto este
año de los 18 cuando quise salir a
marchar en el orgullo de buenos aires
quise escribir un cartel que diga vih
sin medicación me muero
estábamos con mis amigas y literal que
me largué a llorar porque dije a quien
le importa que yo me muera si alguien
tiene aprobó un presupuesto de gobierno
que casi me cubre la medicación vih a
quien importa que yo me muera si en las
marchas somos tan pocas y pocos
entonces saben que lo cambie ese cartel
vih-positivo y orgulloso
ahí sí que todos se hicieron cargo de mi
mensaje se enojaron metro le ataron y
demás saben cuál es mi orgullo mi
orgullo no es vivir con un virus ni
orgullos estar de pie acá vivo en una
sociedad que me ignora
[Aplausos]
en una sociedad que nos ignora y que no
nos quiere mi venganza es mi sonrisa
y esa tarde
marcharon conmigo todas mis amigas y
amigos yo no sé si ezequiel si lucas si
mis demás amigos y maru son mediante
positivos expresa tarde lo fueron y su
orgullo también fue ese fue salir y
marchar
acá escalo de vih digo que la h
es de humano entonces no importa que
seas heterosexual homosexual no importa
el virus no va a discriminar eso
pero saben que con los días también
aprendí y con los abrazos y el recorrido
que la h es de humanidad humanidad que
tenemos cuando dejamos de ser
estadísticas cuando dejamos de ser
simplemente una porción olvidada como no
estoy con mis amigas y mis amigos por
eso les pido que vivan con vih para
accionar para exigirle a los gobiernos
para exigir a la sociedad para
informarse para que cuando una persona
los elija y les dé ese regalo de la
información
sepan recibirlo actualmente yo soy un
activista que exige la cura
pero cuando no nos dan la medicación
su significación me muero para llegar
vivo a la cura yo necesito mi medicación
el cuerpo vih es un cuerpo político si a
mí me falta medicación que está pasando
en otras situaciones de salud del país y
del mundo entonces porque ustedes
piensan que me tener vih no los incluye
yo soy lucas y yo tengo vih yo cuando
les pido que vivan con vih
lo que les pido es que vivan con empatía
que iván con orgullo que vivan con
fuerza con celebración pero por sobre
todo lo que les pido lo que no os pido
es que vivamos que lleguemos vivos y
vivas a la cura del vih y mientras no
podamos curar el vih si podemos curar la
desidia la falta de empatía la violencia
eso sí lo podemos curar
yo soy lukas y tengo vih
yo soy lucas
y tengo vida gracias
[Aplausos]